TO "HANNITY."
IT WAS ANOTHER DAY OF
CONTROVERSY FOR HUNTER BIDEN.
HIS ART SHOW CONTINUES TO RAISE
MOUNTING ETHICS CONCERNS.
EXPERTS SAYING THESE AMATEUR ART
PIECES EXPECTED TO SELL FOR
$500,000 ARE OVERPRIZED AND
A FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN WILL
INTERVIEWS A BILL TO PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY TO HUNTER BIDEN'S
SECRET BUSINESS DEALINGS.
HE JOINS NOW WITH THE LATEST
WITH FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR LAURA
TRUMP.
CONGRESSMA
CONGRESSMAN, CONGRATULATIONS.
THEY SAID IT'S ALL FINE.
KUDOS FOR THINKING OF A BILL.
WHAT WILL IT DO?
>> HUNTER BIDEN IS AN ARTIST.
HE IS A CON ARTIST.
THAT'S THE TYPE OF ARTIST HE IS.
LET'S ARE REVIEW HIS GALLERY
CORRUPTION.
EXHIBIT-A, BURISMA.
HUNTER BIDEN ON THE BOARD OF ONE
OF THE MOST CORRUPT COUNTRIES IN
THE COUNTRY.
EXHIBIT B, CHINA FLIES WITH
VICE-PRESIDENT BIDEN ON AIR
FORCE 2 AND 1.5-BILLION DOLLARS
INVESTED WITH THE CENTRAL BANK
OF CHINA.
DO THIS DAY, JUDGE, AN EQUITY
HOLDER IN THE CHINESE NUCLEAR
GROUP.
AND EXHIBIT-C, THIS CORRUPT NEW
ART BUSINESS.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
IT BILL WOULD FORCE DISCLOSURE.
I WANT TO KNOW WHO IS
CIRCUMVENTING THE AND
GETTING TO THE WHITE HOUSE THIS
ART.
>> HE SEEMS TO BE AN EXPERT AT
BRINGING IN MONEY AND THE LAPTOP
WHICH WAS HIS.
HE DIDN'T DENY IT.
GIVE 10% TO THE BIG GUY.
I COULD NOT HELP BUT THINK HOW
THE LEFT TRIED TO MAKE EVERY DAY
HELL FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON HOW THIS
FAMILY HAS BEEN ABLE TO GET AWAY
WITH IT?
>> WELL, ALL OF IT IS A SHAME
AND A SHAM AND TERRIBLE FOR
AMERICA.
CONGRESSMAN WALT Z'S BILL IS
A GREAT IDEA.
IN AMERICA YOU HAVE TO FORCE
TRANSPARENCY IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE NO ONE
KNOWS WHO IS BUYING THESE ART
PIECES.
I DIDN'T NEED THE EXPERTS TO
TELL ME THEY WERE OVERPRIZED.
FOR FUTURE NON-DEPENDENTS OF
PRESIDENTS, IT WILL FORCE THEM
TO DISCLOSE THEIR FINANCIAL
INFORMATION.
THIS IS THE ONE KID THAT CAN'T
BEHAVE AT RECESS SO THE WHOLE
CLASS GETS PUNISHED.
IT WILL BE NICE TO KNOW WHAT IS
HAPPENING BEHIND-THE-SCENES.
WE KNOW THAT HUNTER BIDEN WAS
DEPENDENT ON JOE BIDEN AND HIS
POSITION IN GOVERNMENT FOR MANY,
MANY YEAR TO BILLION DOLLARS OF
PROFIT FOR THE BIDEN FAMILY.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS.
HE HAD NO EXPERIENCE THAT GOT
HIM AT JOB THE BURISMA.
THAT WAS BECAUSE HIS DAD WAS
VICE-PRESIDENT.
GETTING MONEY FROM CHINA AND
RUSSIA BECAUSE HIS DAD WAS
VICE-PRESIDENT HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH HIS SKILL SET.
IT WOULD BE NICE TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF WHAT HE IS MAKING
MONEY FOR.
>> CONGRESSMAN, I DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF FAITH IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE GETTING TO THE BOTTOM
OF ANYTHING.
HE IS RIGHT.
WE NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
IT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THE DOJ WILL.
WHAT ARE THE CHANCES OF YOUR
BILL GETTING PASSED?
>> WELL, I AGREE WITH YOU ON THE
DOJ.
THE FACT THAT HE WAS UNDER
INVESTIGATION DURING THE 2020
ELECTION AND THE DOJ DECIDED NOT
TO REVEAL THAT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVED TO
KNOW THAT BEFORE THEY CAST THEIR
VOTES.
I DON'T THINK WE SEE THIS TO
MOVE UNTIL WE FIRE NANCY PELOSI
IN 15 MONTHS AND SEND HER BACK
TO HER ICE CREAM IN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN WE DO TAKE THE MAJORITY WE
ARE GOING TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF THESE BUSINESS DEALINGS FROM
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
WHAT I WANT TO KNOW IS WHAT KIND
OF BUSINESSES ARE THE CHINESE
DIRECTING HUNTER TO GIVE THEM
ACCESS TO?
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY IS
NOT GIVING HIM A BILLION DOLLARS
TO BUY A SHOE STRING FACTORY IN
MICHIGAN.
THEY WANT ROBOTICS AND ART  --
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE TO
DOMINATE THE UNITED STATES.
I THINK THERE IS A LOT MORE
SHOES TO DROP HERE.
>> I DON'T THINK THERE IS CAN
ANY QUESTION THERE ARE A LOT
MORE SHOES TO DROP.
THE LAST QUESTION TO YOU, WITH
RESPECT TO HUNTER BIDEN AND THE
SALE OF THIS SO-CALLED ART, DO
YOU THINK WE WILL EVER BE ABLE
TO FIND OUT?
LET'S ASSUME THE BILL DOESN'T
PASS.
WILL WE EVER GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF THAT OR WILL THEY SHOVEL IN
MILLIONS THROUGH THE FUNNEL
CALLED ART?
>> UNFORTUNATELY WE PROBABLY
WILL NEVER KNOW.
WITH THE BIDEN FAMILY IT'S
COVER-UP AFTER COVER-UP AND HELP
FROM THE DNC AND THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA.
WE WILL NEVER GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF THIS.
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S TISSUE FOR
PERK.
WHAT A BAD PRECEDENT SOMETHING
LIKE THIS COULD SET.
IT'S FRUSTRATING TO SEE BECAUSE
AS YOU KNOW, AS I SAY AND YOU
HEAR FROM OUR FAMILY, WHEN MY
FATHER-IN-LAW WAS PRESIDENT, WE
WENT OUT OF OUR WAY TO MAKE SURE
THERE WAS FULL TRANSPARENCY.
WE DIDN'T HAVE TO DO IT BUT PAID
EVERY DOLLAR THAT ANY FOREIGN
ENTITY PAID FOR A TRUMP PRIORITY
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES
TREASURE.
THEY STILL CAME AFTER US AND
STILL CONTINUE TO COME AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE PROSECUTORS IN NEW YORK ARE
DISGRACEFUL LETTING CRIMINALS
GOING AND GOING AFTER DONALD
TRUMP AND THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION
FOR NOTHING.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
>> IT'